I'm going to focus on Interactive 3D rendering in particular. Let's break that
phrase down starting from the end. This last word, rendering, means depiction.
Well, it can also mean translating to another language, or turning animals into
meat, but let's ignore those definitions. An artist can render a scene by
painting it, an architect can render a building in perspective. And so on. To
render means to create an image. For the phrase 3D, this means defining things
in a three-dimensional world. In the field of 3D computer graphics, you
mathematically define objects, materials, lights, and a camera. And then use
these together to render onto a 2-dimensional screen. Your monitor becomes a
window into this world that you've created. Even newer smart phones have 3D
graphic accelerators in them. You've undoubtedly seen video games and special
effects in movies. These are two of the most obvious uses of computer rendering
techniques. There are a vast number of other uses of 3D rendeing that effects
how the world works. Architects commonly create 3D graphics presentations for
their own benefit and for clients. Engineers use rendering to help show
potential problems with their designs. Doctors use 3D reconstructions from
medical scanning devices to understand patients problems. Even lawyers will
employ 3D animations to help explain accidents or other events. Interactive
means you can instantly influence what you see on the screen. Video games give
us obvious examples. You turn the wheel left in a racing game, and go that
direction. Compare this to say, playing a DVD. There's perhaps, some minimal
control that could be considered interactive, pause, fast forward and so on. But
you're not affecting the world itself in any way. Drawing these lines is
interactive, I'm affecting what I see, but it's 2-dimensional. By Interactive
3D, I mean that the users actions affect something in a 3D virtual world At the
least, you move the camera to the world, possibly affecting objects and lighting
as you go. This program by James Gow shows MRI data of how the brain is
stimulated when exposed to different objects and actions. On the right is the 2D
system for picking an object, on the left you then see the area stimulated. You
can also change the view and with the slider, control how the data is
represented. I asked Jack Galiant, who helped with this program, about how much
of the brain is dedicated to processing what out eyes see. The answer is, that
more than a quarter of our brain is involved in interrupting visible signals. I
should note that there are other areas of computer graphics having to do with
images but are not truly 3D rendering. For example there's a complementary field
called image processing. Where you use the computer to analyze photographs or
other images and try to extract a mathematical description of the world from
them. Though graphics hardware can definitely accelerate image processing
operations. We'll mostly be focused on 3d rendering in this course.